[Music]
when I was ten I wanted to take apart my
mom's Underwood typewriter and was
really pretty different kinds of
materials shiny black paint and chrome
and nickel plated parts it looked very
organic and I just wanted to see what
was inside of it I finally got a chance
to take one apart when I was in my 20s
and I decided that you know I try to
make something out of it I'm Jeremy
mayor and I make sculptures out of
typewriter parts for more than two
decades artist Jeremy Mayer has been
disassembling typewriters piece by piece
and then carefully turning them into
remarkably detailed sculptures of birds
insects and people I think the reason I
do living things with the typewriters is
that the typer has to be powered by us
it has to start with our fingers so it's
based entirely on our actions our shape
the designs of the components match a
lot of different things in nature I mean
I just saw that the first time I opened
one up and then spread it out it all
looks like pieces of plants or cell
structure or feathers it didn't make any
sense to do anything else with it I
think the best path for a machine to
take you know path of entropy is for it
to turn back into something that
inspired it in the first place where
most might see a broken and outdated
machine mayor sees fingers and faces and
more you know that's a wing it's in you
know by itself it's an individual
feather but what this is is a typewriter
but it's a tight bar actually as the
letters on it and it it's it's the
rubber platen and transfers the letters
onto the paper
it's a raven the torso is the it's the
back of royal typewriters by name senior
royal this is a bell these are main
Springs that allow the carriage to come
back after you push it mayor makes his
pieces within a strict set of creative
rules the first only typewriter pieces
to make the sculptures I
completely disassembled typewriter down
to its most basic components I all
looked like an erector set or Legos or
some kind of puzzle so I figured that
just do the hardest possible thing and
that was just to assemble it as it was
the second as little modification to the
parts as possible
I used to alter pieces more so the rule
that I wouldn't alter or drill or screw
or cut kind of came later I'm still
working around that one like if I do any
of those things you can't see it the
third the only way to assemble the
sculptures is by using original
typewriter parts wires bolts and nuts no
tape no glue no welding if I didn't have
these rules I think you'd see that
you'll be able to see that I didn't
spend enough time I could just weld this
stuff together and you would look at
that and you'd say well it did it it
made it to this certain shape but that's
for me that's not enough the
interconnectedness of the parts is
interesting in me and the heart the more
rules I have on it the more surprised I
am by the outcomes mayors rules mean
that constructing a sculpture can take a
lot of time you know the Raven it took
about a month to do it from typewriter
to sculpture the way I get there is
first obviously I got to get the
typewriters have friends who repair them
who give me they're broken ones
sometimes people will text me and text
me a picture of the typewriter and say
hey this is 50 bucks and I said yeah
talk them down to 20 I'll take it so
when I have time I take them apart or if
I need them if I need a specific
component I'll take it apart then I have
to take those pieces you know organize
them mayor keeps the little bits loosely
organized around his studio lots of keys
sometimes of keys and just keep
everything labeled but eventually it all
winds up on the floor once it hits the
floor then I need to keep it organized
when it's on the floor it's next to
things it's related to so I have ideas
about what I want to do with it next
when I start to assemble if I have a
formula I start to use it if not then I
spend a bunch of time playing around
trying to figure out how to how the
thing can hold its own weight like this
this Ravens got to stand on its own feet
so that took a while to figure out you
know how to balance this whole thing so
there's a lot of assembly and then
disassembly and then reassembly over and
over again I could I could assemble an
entire arm on a full-scale figure and it
doesn't quite look right I have to take
the whole thing apart may or may spend a
year or more working on his larger
sculptures full-scale human figures
usually have components from about 15
machines you know these are little bars
that the tight bars
rest on where they when you hit the key
the typebar comes up and it falls back
down at rests on this curve thing and
all each one of these is from one
smith-corona typewriter I had to collect
that same typewriter for about probably
six years before I could even make those
rooms clears rules can lead to
incredible frustration if I were younger
there would be a lot more holes in the
walls in here from selling tools or
throwing stuff but I don't do that
anymore it's kind of read through it
it'll figure itself out eventually
I've always thought the art that's
hardest to make is is trying not to get
made in the same way that particles kind
of try to avoid detection
it takes increasing the amounts of
energy to see smaller and smaller
particles
I think arts kind of the same way that
if it's if it's difficult to reach your
vision the harder it is the harder it'll
fight you and the harder you have to
push through that and injuries are also
common I cut myself every day I don't
know if I'm bad at it or
I'm uncoordinated or what but well it
happens when you sharpen your
screwdrivers but I have to sharpen them
otherwise it they wouldn't work but
after he's pushed through how does he
know a piece is finished sometimes I
know a piece is done just by I feel like
I'm done it looks done I'm happy with it
sometimes I know right when I do that
last twist of the screw sometimes I
don't know it until I walk in the room
next morning but the last full-scale
human figure I did I knew when the
snapchat filter for the face worked and
it applied the filter and I was okay
that word that's that's good that's done
that kind of fidelity has made Maier's
work sought-after by collectors
different people like my work for
different reasons doctors and and people
into biology and anatomy like my work
the hands are just made from keys
they're just like the hand they're a
mirror image of the physical process of
what your fingers do I think when
they're anatomically accurate there's
it's a good base for a personality like
that bird it's definitely just a raven
but but if you just cut out of the
corner of your eye you'd be waiting for
it to do something you'd be waiting for
it jump it has it has a presence there
when I do the anatomy accurately then
that's a good base for creating a like a
personality for the piece over the top
of it
many of his patrons also work in tech
which might seem odd at first because
after all their industry essentially
killed the typewriter I think it has
something to do with the keyboard but
it's also I think protect people a way
to look backward and say here's
something with captain this is part of
the seed of this good idea that we have
about moving forward one might expect
after more than 20 years of working with
typewriters that mayor would be an
excellent typist with a love of the
analog writing style no I'm uh
typist I hate typing on typewriters I'd
rather write if I'm gonna write somebody
letter and those mayor's work is
entirely typewriter based he is not
precious about the old machines another
reason people are interested in the
typewriter like I'll tell them I take
apart typewriters and they go oh I don't
know how I feel about that
like there's this sorrow this you know
we don't feel bad for the machine we
feel bad for us we feel bad for
something that we we said oh we
shouldn't destroy that yet because we
don't know what we're missing I
I kind of do know a missing that's the
point of doing this isn't it
oh I want to keep this on I throw this
away this is this is junk this was a
terrible typewriter it shouldn't even be
used anymore this one's really nice this
one's beautiful where this one works
really well I decided that I'm the
person who gets to do that in this
context and while he doesn't enjoy
typing mayor hasn't lost interest in
finding feathers and faces among the
space bars and ribbons of the old
machines the only reason I can think of
they keep working with the stuff is that
it just it doesn't get boring it's still
interesting to me
[Music]
you